witchcraft accusation is something
that ruins your life for
for a long long time
phoenix faith is speaking publicly for
the first time about her alleged ordeal
as a child she says she was accused of
witchcraft by a faith leader who claimed
she had caused phoenix's mother's cancer
phoenix says it led to her facing months
of physical and emotional abuse this
included her being subjected to an
exorcism where her head was shaved
i literally had no hair anymore and
and when i went to school i remember i
used to have this
man sorry
i used to have this bandana back in the
day it was a
blue and
i would put down my head and
i'd have people you know yank it away
and run away and like raise all your
hair gone it's all your hair going
phoenix has concerns that the faith
leader may still be operating in the uk
today
i just knew that he was wrong
and
if this person was so powerful and god
is speaking through them why do you have
to beat me or starve me
just being made to admit to things that
you're so young to even comprehend was
just
a very horrible and
boggling
cases of abuse linked to witchcraft
beliefs have had fatal consequences in
the uk eight-year-old victoria columbia
was tortured to death over claim she was
possessed in the year 2000 and 15 year
old christie bami was drowned in a bath
during an exorcism on christmas day in
2010
children's charity barnardos has
concerns that cases may have been missed
during the covid lockdowns with victims
previously facing horrific abuse
people are made to to drink or to eat
certain things they are they're burnt um
they're they're cut so the idea is that
by cutting them you create an opening
for if there's an evil spirit inside
that person that would leave their body
phoenix reported her allegations to
police in 2020 but the case was closed
last year due to insufficient evidence
she has now urged people suffering from
abuse linked to witchcraft beliefs to
contact police i would implore you to
please come forward and go to the police
and report it or if you know anyone
who has confided in you
because this thing is a virus and
it's a hidden virus that you don't hear
of
with police warning that cases of
witchcraft abuse are under-reported
there are fears that more victims like
phoenix may be suffering in silence
david mercer sky news